[SPEAKER_00]: Sometimes the greatest failures are remembered as well as the greatest victories.
[SPEAKER_00]: And such was the truth for Folsom's performance of the brewing storm at the marine barracks in Monmurg City.
[SPEAKER_00]: His admonition of the Sea Princes, all of them, Lord Jamis,
[SPEAKER_01]: Prince Jeon, Prince Fairwind, Prince Flotsam, Prince Jetsam, and Prince Toli would be etched in the mind of all of those Marines who, at the time, would grumble and seem angry at such thoughts, particularly because of their great patriotic feelings towards the sea principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, as the days and weeks rolled on,
[SPEAKER_01]: Rumors, Fairwinds,
[SPEAKER_01]: Treachery at Helm Island and the sightings of the sea ghost and the actions of the Toli reinforced Folsom's prediction.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the Marines began to realize that Folsom had insight into the future and what was coming their way.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they grudgingly accepted the wisdom of what he had said to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was a storm brewing.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it was not just the Duke of Gradsall's doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: The jealousy and infighting of the sea princes added to the confusion and to the country's troubles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Soon they realized that Folsom was correct.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was a problem outside the principalities, but there were many problems within as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the troubles of the nation were not just from its enemies, but from its supposed friends as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Marines talked to one another about the song and its meaning and actually in time they began to wish that they could speak with Folsom and see what else he knew.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thus began Folsom's career in infamy as a bard of lore.